by the way do you see the trailer for
Top Gun maverick that's a lot stalking
okay wanted to do as a poll question
today you know whose birthdays today
Anthony Edwards you know who he was
gugus who's the greatest movie sidekick
cash oh God on the same page you can't
go tango and cash I just knew that that
made history I knew that was there I was
just I was just feeding the monster
thank you for lack of a better term by
the way I did you how many times have
you seen the trailer
zero times I've seen the trailers zero
times I saw it today was pretty good I'm
not gonna lie okay I'm sure it's great
and I'm sure I can't wait
miles teller gonna have to wait till
2020 miles teller plays gooses son who's
also a fighter pilot
oh my god and he must carry the burden
right yes you are not here for my table
here in the last segment on a Friday
talking about gooses it's not that
spoiler alert yeah six well 86th and
it's really strange in that scene where
gooses son gets a cymbal thrown at him
by the by the crazy music professor I'm
sorry that was miles tellers other movie
yeah I got totally confused miles teller
is like one of those guys that's in
every other movie right like he's out
there all along no kidding yeah I feel
like oh mile cellars in that too
fantastic for myself any pass zn0 miles
teller who who would have been who would
have been me who would have been the
your dog's miles teller put it in your
so it would have been your sidekick we
were we were talking these Chewbacca
okay that's more ensemble right than
sidekick grab out come on he's the Hans
number two the Sundance Kid yeah I would
go come on that's my defense that's your
that's what Sundance Kitty huh me don't
you yeah I'm six tops top five how about
this
jonathan mardukas the duke yeah such i
watching so again
try here pull on the I wish so no I just
like you do I love my listeners yes I
consider them and people there might
there may consider them people well no
carbon-based life-forms fantastic I do
consider their carbon but the highest
form of carbon-based life-forms they're
my people
but they let me down a very this sort
was sorely just they didn't what hole is
that I didn't think we're not aware of
this film they're not not big fans no
midnight Robbo it was up again it was up
against some serious competition about
what was it like it wasn't like best in
Euro movie or something like that was it
underappreciated best comedy buddy
comedy yeah best come on good come on
they they did not what did they have in
front know whose brothers lethal weapon
in lethal weapon yeah lethal weapon top
gun Walsh in the two blues brothers Duke
were very good Dennis Farina very
underrated and very much so very under
when do you head back to Tuesday on the
midnight on the red-eye so here for the
go to my first ever Dodger game tonight
are you really how about that I just
want total students there I apologize
about that yeah we've never I've never
been so we're going we're going to see
them play the Marlin some Marlins oh
she's returned there you go to Dodger
Stadium Donnie baseball for me always
always Donnie baseball it's you talking
to me every year he set some sort of
benign record that no one had ever heard
of but he did it you know the holes most
hits most day long most games of the
home run yeah that's me there you go
that was me that's one of my favorite
story it's just real quick I was at
Michigan yes Mattingly was under the
thumb of George Steinbrenner correct and
Steinbrenner was treating him like
garbage it was just the hair debacle and
the Yankees were in Tiger Stadium yeah I
drove all the way down from the campus
in Ann Arbor rent it's like borrowed a
car to go down and it's just practiced
my soliloquy I was going to personally
save Mattingly from leaving in free
agency to escape Steinbrenner I was
going to take matters into my own
you were gonna be the guy correct and I
practiced my spiel as they say all the
way down I got to Tiger Stadium the old
Tiger stage right for they unlock the
gates they were locked padlocked I was
the first one in first one in the
stadium the first one belly up to the
Yankees visiting dugout nice first guy
out of the clubhouse of course because
he's a lead-pipe wielding professional
and great human being done Don Mattingly
and all I went was go ahead
[Music]
you know what no but you were there you
were there he got wide-eyed pirouette it
back in you scared him back inside but
he didn't leave via free agency he did
not leave because he knew that there
were fans like there's but I respect
that like for example we had tickets to
two events in June of 1987 and we
decided to go with it was the YouTube
Joshua Tree concert in Hartford or a
Yankees baseball game in 1987 and we
went to see the Yankees game just to see
Don Mattingly damn straight man it was
not even a debate and did hear Hartford
[Laughter]
it'll be a blast you grow up in
Fairfield County Connecticut Hartford is
this other and now where are you taking
the red-eye back Tuesday Hartford very
excited about it very excited but be
great Hartford international Bradley
internationally oh that's for Bradley at
national BDL one of my favorite things
drive one of the craziest things when I
used to live there in Farmington your
West Hartford is watching Manute Bol
just stroll around yeah that's where he
retired to Fri Yasin I actually flew
back once from the NBA Austrian with
Manute Bol in first class he looked like
an accordion like this it was incredible
and that's like you know he needs
hitting first class he needs like extra
primo super superior okay well just know
this schedule time to get in to Dodger
Stadium in hell it's the it's true yeah
it's true
you should leave early if you can yes
that's true
knowing knowing this group mates going
your that's probably going man you
definitely need to get a Dodger table
yeah others say re they are but don't
have 70 of them and dip them into water
in the wind it will be no splash zone in
front of us I can promise you that I can
recommend the helmet churro sundae
okay enjoy tonight thank you sir a
Twingo z on twitter at trace on
instagram Golic and Wingo every single
day 6 a.m. to 10 a.m. NFL primetime ESPN
and so much more good to see a button
always a pleasure for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on Direct TV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app